how to calculate a two-way Anova a
two-way Anova is a statistical method
used to test the effect of two
categorical variables on a continuous
variable the categorical variables are
the independent variables for example
the variable drag type with drag A and B
and gender with female and male and the
continuous variable is the dependent
variable for example the red reduction
in blood pressure so we would like to
know if drag type and gender have an
influence on the reduction in blood
pressure drag type has the two levels
drug A and B and gender has the two
levels male and female to answer the
question we collect data we randomly
assigned patients to the treatment
combinations and measured the reduction
in blood pressure after a month for
example the first first patient receives
drug a is male and after one month a
reduction in blood pressure of six was
measured now let us answer the questions
is there a main effect of drag type on
the reduction in blood pressure is there
a main effect of gender on the reduction
in blood pressure and is there an
interaction effect between drag type and
gender on the reduction but what does an
analysis of variance actually do and why
is the word variance in analysis of
variance in a two-way analysis of
variance the total variance of the
dependent variable is divided into the
variance that can be explained by factor
a the variance that can be explained by
Factor B the variance of the interaction
and the arror variance actually SS is
not the variance but the sum of squares
we will discuss ask how to calculate the
variance in this case in a moment but
how can I imagine that the dependent
variable has some variance in our
example not everyone will have the same
reduction in blood pressure we now want
to know if we can explain some of this
variance by the variable stru type
gender and their interaction the part
that we cannot explain by these three
terms accumulates in the error if if the
result looked like this we would be able
to explain almost all the variance by
factors A and B and their interaction
and we would only have a very small
proportion that could not be explained
in this case it would be the other way
around drag type gender and the
interaction almost have no effect on the
reduction in blood pressure and it all
adds up in the arrow but how do we
calculate the sum of squares the F value
and the P value here we have our data
one's drug type with drug A and B and
one's gender with male and female so
these individuals are for example all
male and have been given drug a first we
calculate the mean values we need we
calculate the mean value of each group
so male and drag a that is 5.8 then male
and Drug B that is 5.4 and we do the
same for female then we calculate the
mean value of all males and females and
the mean value of drug A and B finally
we need the total mean we can now start
to calculate the sum of squares let's
start with the total sum of squares we
do this by subtracting the total mean
from each individual value squaring the
result and adding up all the values the
total mean is 5.4 so we calculate 6 -
5.4 2ar + 4 - 5.4 squared to finally 3 -
5.4 squar so we get a sum of squares of
84.8 the degrees of freedom are given by
n * P * Q - 1 n is the number of people
in a group in our case five F and P and
Q are the number of categories in each
of the factors in both cases we have two
groups the total variance is calculated
by dividing the sum of squares by the
degrees of freedom so we get
4.46 now we can calculate the sum of
squares between the groups for this we
calculate the group mean minus the total
mean so 5.8 - 5.4 s
+ 5.4 - 5.4 sared and the same for these
two values we get
7.6 in this case the degrees of freedom
are three which gives us a variance of
2.53 now we can calculate the sum of
squares of factor a a dash is the mean
value of the categories of factor a so
we calculate
5.9 us the total mean value and 4.9
minus the total mean value this results
in five together with the degrees of
freedom we can now calculate the
variance for factor a which is five we
do the same for Factor B in this case we
use the mean values of male and female
and we get the variance of
0.8 now we can calculate the sum of
squares for the interaction we obtain
this by calculating the sum of squares
minus the sum of squares of A and B the
decrees of Freedom result to one for the
interaction we get a variance of
1.8 finally we can calculate the sum of
squares of the error we substract the
mean value of each group from the
respective group values so in this group
we substract 5.8 from each individual
value in this group we substract
5.4 here we substract six and then we
substract 4.4 this gives us a sum of
squares of
77.2 the degrees of freedom are 16 and
we get a variance of
4.83 and now we calculate the F values
these are obtained by dividing the
variance of factor a b or the
interaction by the arrow variance so we
get the F value for factor a by dividing
the variance of factor a by the eror
variance which is equal to
1.04 we can now do exactly the same for
FB and faab to verify we get exactly the
same values with data
1.04
0.17 and
0.37 for the calculation of the P value
you need the degrees of freedom and the
F distribution so with these three
values you can either read the critical
P value in a table or as usual you just
use a software to calculate the P values
you can find a table of critical F
values on data tab a g for a
significance level of 5% you can use
this table if the red value is greater
than the calculated F value the null
hypothesis is rejected otherwise not I
hope you enjoyed the video and see you
next
time